alors oui vous avez compris je veux être
la candidate du pouvoir d'achat j'ai une
proposition c'est d'augmenter de 10% les
salaires nets sur le quinquennat si on
veut baisser les impôts et on est
champion du monde des impôts va falloir
réduire les dépenses c'est travailler
pour gagner et moi ce que je veux c'est
que le travail paye
aujourd'hui les salaires ne sont plus
assez élevé on le voit bien avec la
hausse des prix c'est plus possible il
ya tellement de français qui pour qui la
fin du mois commence le 10 et puis il ya
aussi un sujet c'est les rtt et d'un
mois j'autoriserai le la conversion des
rtt en salaire sans charges patronales
pour qu' on puisse justement te donner
du pouvoir d'achat à ceux qui en ont
besoin
[Applaudissements]
cordages à sa frappe par le travail on
va gagner et on va remettre ce pays sur
pied et pour gagner j'ai besoin de vous
j'ai besoin de chacun d'entre vous j'ai
besoin de votre énergie j'ai besoin de
vous allier convaincre j'ai besoin vous
alliez porter ma parole j'ai besoin de
chacun d'entre vous les amis et je vous
le dis si vous êtes au rendez vous nous
irons toi
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]